[Musique]
ce vendredi 20 mai s'est déroulée la
remise de prix du concours d'élevage à
l'occasion de la foire agricole de
bras-panon
les meilleurs éleveurs locaux sont
récompensés par le département acteur
majeur de la politique agricole je crois
que surtout après deux années d'absence
montrer aux éleveurs puisque ce prix
agricoles est destiné aux éleveurs des
différentes filières viande que le
conseil départemental continue à
soutenir les acteurs du monde agricole
et plus particulièrement les éleveurs
nous avons vu ce matin des éleveurs
venir en famille ça montre aussi que le
modèle agricole réunionnais et bien ce
modèle familial qu'on soutient c'est un
modèle qui doit perdurer dans le temps
et je crois qu'on a eu aussi le
témoignage poignant de reprise
d'exploitation ou encore de famille unie
dans ce canton et éleveurs c'est du
lundi au dimanche de 4 heures du matin
jusqu'à 20h donc c'est un une activité
extrêmement prenante et et le soutien et
la mise en avant et la reconnaissance
que nous appelons donc à ces
professionnels ne semble nécessaire
utile pour pouvoir mettre en avant
l'agriculture réunionnaise les filières
viandes de la réunion et inviter tous
notre population à manger de la viande
payé un prix synonyme de reconnaissance
pour ces professionnels
c'est que ça coûte y et puis
on est on est reconnu comme un don mello
a fait des bonnes choses
on dit on veut l'honnêteté
fleuriront et là des zones est et
périront
société mais oui c'est une récompense le
travail qu a fait toute l'année la
filiale a beaucoup d'amis et nous aussi
nous les jeunes nous faisait bien
continuer sur cette lancée
plus tôt dans la matinée elle une
conférence technique sur le feader fonds
européen agricole pour le développement
rural destiné à aider les agriculteurs
[Musique]